hey i'm david dobrik and today i'm gonna
be answering fan questions while playing
with some puppies are they just gonna
run to me it's that no should I grab
them I should warn everybody I'm really
bad at holding dogs they all look like
little Scooby Doo's come here we're
gonna answer questions it takes me about
a it takes me about two days all my
knowledge of anything went out the
window cuz I feel like I'm trying to
take care of these guys and that look
like I don't know how to do it really
really nice and really easy to talk to I
don't know why every time I film with a
celebrity after I film with him I'm like
how are they so nice as if like they're
not supposed to be nice and she's she
was great she's so great Ryan Reynolds I
don't know he's just he's so funny all
around and he's like a really
good-looking guy he's the perfect man I
feel like it's coming off like I'm in
love with him Daniel Radcliffe
I got compared to Harry Potter as a kid
a lot there's one there's a vine I did
outside of my high school and it had
like the name of my high school on the
outside and it did really well and I was
really excited because I really liked my
high school so I was happy that my high
school is associated with something that
did well um so is that one for sure
Jason would survive like through the
middle he'd do really well Scott would
survive the longest so with Todd and
Jeff Zane would die first and then the
rest of us would just be hanging out
right just hanging out Josh Peck because
he's been doing this with me the longest
my friends and the things around me my
friends my friends are big inspirations
let's just add the help for my friends I
don't know if this is there's not really
any like thought process that goes into
NES whoa apologize it's okay I'm not
talking I've been lucky to record every
moment in the past two years where I
can't even think of anything but maybe
maybe where a relationship started where
someone asked somebody out or something
that could have been cool but that's
like a private thing so I don't really
know about that I literally can't think
do people answer these questions oh I
really like dude perfect
they do a bunch of trick shots I'm sure
people know and I love I love watching
trick shots because I would always try
to do them as a kid and I didn't know
how yeah you can't go anywhere now okay
okay okay okay guys we had to remove the
puppies because it was too distracting
um I would I would say to watch movies
I'm like I'm like a big movie guy movies
or or playing basketball which I haven't
I'm like seven months but I'd like doing
that I'd be a teacher I was really close
to a lot of my teachers and I feel like
teaching is kind of like being a
youtuber I don't know I like teaching
people things I don't know why even
though I've probably never taught
anybody anything but um I feel like I'd
be a really good time and I would and I
really want to like I want to go into
like the teachers workroom and like talk
about the students and this guy socks
and whatever
[Music]
I think knowing who you are as a person
and like knowing who your true self is
really helps with ignoring negativity
and just being like that's not that's
not accurate just you should ignore it
it's so it's it's a stupid tip but
that's the best thing to do it's it's
always the same it's always be authentic
don't try to replicate anybody if you're
having fun doing it then your audience
is gonna see that you're having fun
doing it and that's the most important
part always make videos that you're
proud of to the point where if you're at
a party and someone put your video on on
the TV you're not embarrassed at it's on
TV
if that makes sense hey guys these
puppies were provided by Vanderpump dogs
and if you want to go check out all
their stuff and other cute little
puppies and dogs go to Vanderpump a dogs
diet at work he's mine now bye guys
[Music]